la presidenta Dina boluarte criticó las
declaraciones del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro sobre la crisis peruana la
mandataria rechazó todo tipo de
injerencias hacia el Perú y le dijo a
Petro que se dedica a gobernar Colombia
porque sus calles están llenando de
protestas y que deje a los peruanos
resolver sus problemas que fue lo que
ocurrió el pasado 9 de febrero a Gustavo
Petro se le ocurrió ironizar el amplio
despliegue de policías para contener las
marchas de protesta en la capital
peruana ante esto Pedro dijo que en Perú
marchan como nazis contra su propio
pueblo para el parlamento peruano
resultan ofensivas las declaraciones del
presidente colombiano contra la policía
peruana y por eso con 72 votos a favor
29 en contra y siete abstenciones
declaró persona no ingrata Gustavo Petro
los congresistas afirman que el jefe de
estado colombiano no solo ofendía a la
policía de Perú sino también al país y a
todo el pueblo judío al banalizar el
holocausto la moción aprobada por el
congreso de este país Pide a los
ministerios el interior y de relaciones
exteriores ejecutar acciones para que
usaba Petro no ingrese al territorio
peruano